you guys it's been a crazy week in
america and i can't wait to tell you all
about it so let's find out
what happened in a monologue
president trump attended a campaign
rally in florida last night
said colvin 19 oh my god same
when asked if he would commit to a
peaceful transition of power following
the election
president trump this week said quote
well we're gonna have to see what
happens
now if you've ever asked your parents
for anything and they said this
you are fully aware that this means no
i asked my mom to take me to mcdonald's
in 1985 and i'm still waiting to see
what happens
she might the first presidential debate
will take place
next week and will reportedly include
six
topics that will be discussed for 15
minutes each
those topics are help us help please
please help help us please please oh god
how will you help us and the economy
according to the latest numbers the name
karen is decreasing in popularity as a
potential baby name
increasing in popularity vaccine
vaccine stop
biting your brother sometime i knew a
vaccine
vaccine maybe i feel like i knew a
vaccine in school
you did vaccine vaccine oh vaccine i'm
sorry vaccine
vaccine some taco bell restaurants in
canada have begun
selling a limited edition custom red
wine so
if you love taco bell and you love red
wine you need to pick a lane
a man in illinois has kept a buffalo
chicken sandwich that was partially
eaten by richard nixon
in his freezer for 60 years which
explains this segment
of the watergate tapes i swear i had a
buffalo chicken sandwich right here i
only took two bites and now it's gone
i don't remember him sounding so
beautiful but
and finally officials in egypt recently
announced
that 27 sarcophagi have been discovered
in an ancient burial ground and i think
i speak for everyone who's been living
through this year when i say
don't touch it just leave them there oh
my god
and that's the end the monologue
did you like monologue i did it likes
you too bud
tarik likes everything you can't rely on
here
here at the amber ruffin show we've been
working day
and night all week to bring you a very
fun segment
called oh jeez derek
what's wrong nothing tarek if
something's wrong you can always talk to
me about it
is it the pandemic no is it america's
recent reckoning with systemic racism
no it's something little and dumb
hey just because there's a lot of big
stuff going on doesn't mean we should
ignore the little stuff
it's just celebrity gossip it's not
important
hey hey all celebrity gossip is
important
are you upset because ti is being
investigated for an alleged
cryptocurrency investment scheme
is it because will smith had that fresh
prince of bel-air photo shoot with the
cast and then
a separate one with the original op viv
and it's like why wouldn't you just make
the two on vivs married to one another
like america wants
is it because keeping up with the
kardashians is finally coming to an end
oh it is it is
no that's not it but i think i know what
it is
tarek are you upset because you saw mary
j blige on tv the other day and
it reminded you that you desperately
need for her to find love
oh you know what pal couples grow apart
and her being single means she's ready
to fall back in love
heck for all we know she could be
falling in love this very second
she could be shoot she could already be
in love
i just love her so much and i just
wanted to be happy don't you see
she is cause it feels so good when you
let go of all the drama in your life
no more pain no more pain
no more drama no one's ever going to
make her hurt again
hey amber yeah thanks you're welcome bud
and that's the type of stuff you can do
when you get your own show
[Laughter]
mary j blige sketch check and check ha
ha
[Music]
you